alors sur la question de la ressource en
eau et des arbitrages entre
l'environnement l'agriculture et
l'économie touristique
aujourd'hui on a nous une démarche en
matière environnementale très très forte
et on a énormément de projets qui sont
là pour préserver la biodiversité dans
les budgets qui ont été présentés on n'a
pas présenté les 7 millions d'euros
annuels qui sont consacrés tous les ans
pour les tous les travaux en matière de
recherche développement autour de la
biodiversité on a rien qu'autour de la
problématique de nos centrales un projet
qui s'appelle
thermidrobiaux qui suit les populations
de poissons depuis des années c'est
certainement la plus grande séquence de
suivi biologiques actuellement
disponible en France les travaux sont
publics et qui montrent aujourd'hui que
nous n'avons pas d'impact majeur même
pas d'impact des centrales nucléaires et
que la problématique aujourd'hui pour
les populations de poissons c'est bien
le réchauffement global bien avant la
bien avant l'impact des centrales tout
est tout est disponible et nous sommes
convaincus qu'il faut travailler sur un
projet global qui permet de préserver
aussi bien la production d'électricité
que l'agriculture effectivement
effectivement comme ça a été dit par par
un une autre personne il y a une
production différente en été en hiver et
bien sûr qu'un mètre cube d'eau prélevé
en hiver n'a pas la même valeur qu'un
mètre cube d'eau prélevé en été en
situation des tirages donc effectivement
l'agriculture a un positionnement
différent du nôtre donc on doit pouvoir
arriver à gérer les problématiques mais
ça passe par le renforcement de la
protection de l'environnement il n'y a
pas de d'avenir si nous ne protègeons
pas le grand cycle de l'eau si nous ne
permettons pas la percolation des eaux
si nous ne protègeons pas les zones
naturelles en amont et on a au niveau de
DF on sera ravi de vous le présenter un
énorme travail là-dessus aussi bien
autour des barrages qu'autour des
centrales et même au-delà de nos
centrales aujourd'hui pour protéger les
zones humides et préserver dans le Grand
Cycle de